Anfang der Woche findet die 15te in Wien
statt iCore ist die internationale
Konferenz der ombudsinstitutionen für
die Streitkräfte Hauptthema unter den
Delegierten diesmal der Klimawandel und
seine Folgen auch für die Streitkräfte
ins eine riesiges Problem im Moment
vielleicht das riesige Problem des
Moments und ich denke das ist auch
wichtig dass die Leute wirklich
zusammenarbeiten können und wirklich
eine globale Antwort finden können Klima
Veränderungen haben dramatische
Auswirkungen auf große
Bevölkerungsbewegungen zum Beispiel aber
auch auf Katastrophen Einsätze die
notwendig sind bei denen man auch immer
wieder Streitkräfte als assistenzkräfte
braucht über 100 Delegierte aus rund 40
Nationen tauschen ihre Erfahrungen aus
dabei gibt es mehr Parallelen als
angenommen eine Erfahrung die ich
gemacht habe auch in den Gesprächen die
ich ähm in diesen Tagen schon geführt
habe ist
soll man sagen
beruhigend oder auch weniger beruhigend
aber die Beschwerden die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten
Vorbringen sind in allen Streitkräften
gleich da geht es immer um die
Behandlung da geht es um die Unterkünfte
da geht das um das Essen so gesehen
ziehen wir alle an einem Strang weil wir
ja alle wollen dass die Bedingungen für
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
verbessert werden und da ist es
natürlich auch wichtig sich zu vernetzen
weil Erfahrungen die auf der einen Seite
der Welt gemacht wurden früher oder
später auch auf der anderen Seite der
Welt ankommen was für uns in Österreich
Normalität ist nämlich die Kontrolle der
Streitkräfte durch das Parlament ist in
vielen Teilen der Welt noch nicht
erreicht das zentrale Anliegen dieser
Organisation ist die demokratische
Kontrolle der Streitkräfte das ist
wichtig und wir sind hier als Österreich
Beispiel gebend mit unserer Kommission
die auch im Parlament gewählt wird ist
für viele Akteure in anderen Ländern ein
Vorbild die meisten haben ombuds
Einrichtungen allerdings nicht
demokratisch legitimiert sind zurück zum
Hauptthema der 15 e-core-konferenz in
Wien der weltweite Klimawandel es ist
eine der größten Herausforderungen für
die Menschen und damit auch für die
Streitkräfte weil Klimawandel
unglaublich welches verursacht was auch
dann die Streitkräfte betrifft wir sind
ja auch in Österreich gefordert immer
wieder in Assistenz bei Katastrophen
einzuschreiten und daher ein wichtiges
Thema dass wir uns darum kümmern wir tun
das im Bundesheer ja schon seit längerem